dans l'actualité également cette
manifestation aujourd'hui de plusieurs
milliers de victimes de l'amiante
manifestation silencieuse à paris ces
hommes et ces femmes réclament un grand
procès pénal de l'amiante il réclame
également une réelle indemnités à la
hauteur de leur préjudice
on écoute l'une de ses victimes se
manifester aujourd'hui on veut que le
procès en pénal contre les employeurs
qui nous ont empoisonné parce que je
suis aussi une victime de l'amiante et
qui ont fait mourir un nombre
incalculable de victimes ce procès doit
s'ouvrir en doit absolument condamner
les responsables
on manifeste aussi pour que soit
préservée la location des travailleurs
amiante pour leur permettre de partir en
pré retraite anticipée et au manifeste
également pour que le fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes de
l'amiante respectent les délais pour
organiser les victimes qui bien souvent
meurt avant d'avoir été organisée